Speaker 1: Let's check in next with. Oh,
how about Elias from Texas? Elias, welcome.
Speaker 4: And it.
Speaker 1: Hi. Your audio is already glitchy,
but what's going on? You hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Oh.
It is the start of Hispanic Heritage Month
tomorrow. Will you teach your daughter.
Speaker 4: Any Hispanic traditions
by teaching Spanish? How important
is your Hispanic identity to you?
Speaker 1: Well, and Hispanic Heritage Month
starts in the middle of the month.
Speaker 4:
Yeah.
Speaker 1: That's weird
that that doesn't really. Are you sure about
that. Usually it starts on the first. Yeah.
Yeah. Let's see. Yeah, this it's more it start
that you're completely correct. That's bizarre,
but you're completely right. Wow. Elias okay. I
exclusively speaks Spanish to my daughter, so the
idea will be that she with. With me and with my
parents. She. We only speak Spanish to her. Yes.
Speaker 3: We'd be in movement.
Speaker 1: Was that your only question?
Speaker 3: D No, I was.
Speaker 4: Saying like,
do you have any like traditions that
you're also going to like, teacher?
Speaker 1: Absolutely. Well, she is going to
be well versed in the eating of Melanesia,
I can assure you as well as, you know, empanadas
and all of these different things. Yes, there's
going to be all sorts of traditions. She's
going to get the best of both worlds. She'll
get the Argentinean traditions and the Jewish
tradition. So, you know, a lot because of the
entire thing. Pastrami, you know?
Speaker 4: That's amazing. Yeah. So. So
how important is your Hispanic identity to
you? It must be pretty important, since here
you're passing it down to your daughter.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. I don't want that
to be lost. And, you know, to
some degree, I mean, listen,
five generations from now, if my
descendants remain in the United States,
I think it will probably be lost inevitably.
It's very hard to keep it indefinitely.
But for now, I'll do what I can.
Speaker 3: Right? Yeah. All right.
Speaker 4: That was basically it.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you so
much. There is Elias from Texas. Always important
to make every effort to pronounce people's names
correctly. Let's go next to let's try Roy
from South Jersey. Roy, what's going on?
Roy from South Jersey, you are on the air.
Speaker 4: Can you hear me now?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Sir.
I have in my phone a list of topics
that I'd like to discuss whenever I
come on. But this is too pressing
for just a regular list. Yeah,
I went to. I'm in. I'm in Florida. Yep. And
I went to a supermarket, and I saw something.
I saw a mypillow store in the supermarket.
Speaker 1: Now, wait a second. Are you. That
sounds more like something that would happen
in Florida. But you said you're in Florida.
Speaker 4: Yeah. Florida. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Oh, wow. No. Okay. Well,
that's. So there's a Mypillow store inside
of another store. That's interesting.
Speaker 4: I was very worried that they would
do a class action lawsuit against me. But
anyway, you know, I really like how you've
challenged a lot of grifters over the years,
like Dave Rubin, but everyone has
a price. So my question to you is,
if, say, Bill Gates or Elon Musk or whoever said,
I will pay you however much. Yep, name your price.
But I want you to go on the air, on your show in a
Tony the Tiger costume and say, I love kids menus.
They're great. What would your price be?
Speaker 1: Oh, that I mean, that's not I
thought you were going to say to, like, become
a conservative on the air for the next decade
or something like that. I mean, that sounds
kind of funny. I would I would do that for,
you know, I don't know, make me an offer if that's
interesting, a Tony the Tiger outfit and saying
that they're great that that I would I would do
for a lot less and then I would take 90% of the
money and put it back into causes I agree with.
Speaker 4: All right. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right, Roy, I hope my answers were
satisfactory. There is Roy from South Jersey.